love doesn't always end well beasty
trust me let us prove you wrong I saw
that it's a family affair tonight you
brought all the kids you know moms
everywhere saying how the heck does she
do that make it look so easy wrangling
them all and having they wrangle me
honestly they're they're more together
Zahara is the most organized in the
family she looked gorgeous that dress
Jenna was beautiful you know there there
was a picture on the internet like a
side-by-side of your kids and you when
you they were younger and now and we
were all like weird in the time young
everybody what happened I know I don't
know but it's just it's just so
wonderful to have their there any other
my friends you know you and I talked a
little bit about how you felt when you
put on your superhero suit for eternals
and I wonder how did you feel when you
were transformed into Maleficent because
I know you said it puffs you up a little
bit made you feel little strove when you
put on this the eternal suit but this
how do you feel when you're transformed
into her well she's such a
it feels powerful you know it gets hard
not to you're like eight foot tall and
yeah she feels powerful and she feels
quite elegant there's something about
the head wrap and I think because she
was created at that time where there
were those old-time movie stars so she
was kind of made to be a bit like one of
those old-fashioned classic you know so
she's she's a bit she's a bit delicious
I think yeah I encourage everybody to
put on some horns and and feel what it's
like by the way we got this amazing
behind-the-scenes video this time lapse
of the prosthetics and the horns and all
that
what was that real-time process like how
long did it take to get on about an hour
and a half they're really fast no I know
and I thought I heard other people over
like four hours and I feel bad I'm
saying or even longer so no bars there
was two amazing people Tony and Ari and
who would take turns on either
and we just they went through really
quickly they're just amazing and they
tried to make it as painless as possible
so did you realize this is the 20th
anniversary of Girl Interrupted tell me
how your daddy helps you cope with that
illuminate me it was your first Oscar do
you think about that time and what about
that girl I think I think when you go
maybe it's 20 years on in your life and
you kind of cut circle back to that girl
yeah and your kids are teens and you
know my son's closer to I was at that
age and and so uh although all the
things I I love about that girl or I'm
seeing in the spirit of them and it's
helping me to return to myself a little
bit
[Music]
[Applause]